thank you
must understand
how the touch of your hand makes my pose
relaxed
that it's only the thrill of boy meeting
girl
track
well it's physical
[Music]
you must try to ride with know that it
means more than that
[Music]
What's Love Got to Do With It Got to Do
With It what's love but a second-hand
emotion
What's Love Got to Do With It Got to Do
With It who needs a heart when a heart
can be broken
foreign
[Music]
[Laughter]
there's a name for this
there's a phrase that
fans
but whatever
the reason you do it for me
[Music]
well got to do with it got to do with it
what's love but a second anymore
[Music]
you've got to do with it got to do with
it who needs a heart when a heart can be
broken
[Music]
foreign
[Laughter]
[Music]
this way
What's Love Got to Do With It God to do
with it what's love but a second-hand
emotion
what's love we've got to do with it got
to do
[Music]
heart can be broken